combien d'heures ça fait depuis samedi
soir ça fait mon cinquième
set émondeurs travaille sans relâche
depuis bientôt une semaine et le travail
est loin d'être terminé a cédé à la
pression voire un an + percussion dans
la musique a été de piedmont nombreux
sont les foyers qui sont toujours privés
d'électricité presque une semaine après
la tempête bonjour à toutes sortes de
jeux où l'on n'a pas atteint on va chez
chez ma belle soeur en italique prendre
aux douches
eric b ville et sa famille passeront la
fin de semaine en dehors de leur
résidence on a réservé deux nuitées à
montréal on va s'en aller parce qu'on
n'a pas encore d'électricité même si sur
la même rue le courant a été rétabli
chez certains ses voisins voire survenus
chez moi puis je t'aime des privilégiés
qui en avait pour une raison et on
n'avait pas
la soirée
si si le jouet le lampadaire la lumière
de rue à lui mais moi j'ai pas de
courage une
beau temps mauvais temps les équipes
d'hydro-québec sont toujours à l'heure
la pluie dame à savoir ralentir un peu
nos travaux de construction hydro québec
espère pouvoir rétablir le courant d'ici
dimanche dans l'ensemble du réseau grâce
au travail acharné de près de 2000 de
ses employés et de trois dernières
journées qui sont devant nous c'est
beaucoup de travaux pour une clientèle
en vingt ans de plus en plus restreinte
on a des arbres de plus d'un mètre de
diamètre sont tombés sur nos fils qui
ont arraché des poteaux on va devoir
évidemment faire le ménage la végétation
on va devoir aussi planter des poteaux
dans le rock ça va prendre au moins deux
jours de travail pour réalimenter caral
clients si la patience de milliers de
résidents est mise à rude épreuve eric b
ville refuge de celi peut pas être un
patient est en colère contre une
situation comme cela ce sont toutes les
deux sont sur terre et bien il
fonctionnera fallujah personnes string
et qui donc
c'est le temps qui va rétablir les
choses ici a dit yassine la radio canda
piedmont dans les laurentides